[Music]
all right so this is truth-telling time
what was tougher the workouts or the
diet that had to go with the workout oh
my god I must say the diet yeah for sure
I actually enjoyed the workout quite a
lot I don't know I I mean just being
part of this kind of film I was a dancer
when I was younger and I think I've
always been so curious about what it's
like to make these big kind of action
movies and do the stunts and and also
that was one of those things cuz I know
I spoke to Magnus my train in the
beginning where we started the film and
is that what can you do cuz I really
wanted to put on muscle I wanted it to
be strong and he said well it is 80%
what you eat and you need to eat a lot I
had five meals a day okay so what did
the diet consists of less I eat ate even
more when he was a bulking up in the
beginning but during the filming add
three eggs and some fruit after workout
in the morning then at 10:00 I had like
two filets of fish a bowl of rice and
vegetables and then similarity one at
4:00 at 7:00 so at like four huge meals
a day
I think Magnus told me you've been on 12
pounds of muscle yeah but yeah 11 12
yeah did you did you love the way you
look cuz I thought you I mean it was
different because that looked amazing to
me I'm quite you know both my parents
are very small I've always been very
petite so re especially to get the
chance for any role to kind of change
your physicality so for it to kind of
for you to get closer to the character
and and for the character to become what
it should be
I really enjoyed it I mean I wanted that
that's not real life and that was Magnus
very sure to tell me to it's not you
know I'm gonna I'm back on you know I'm
drinking my wine I'm eating my food I
you know I work out and give myself
healthy but
no I'm not doing that regime but I felt
really strong yeah I mean I was able to
like lift my own weight you know to do
six pull-ups I've never been able to do
a pull-up in my life I never thought I
actually didn't even think I was gonna
be able to do that by then I said - I
was at you're never gonna be able to me
I was like that that's just impossible
that's just you know loss of nature it's
not gonna happen what was the first
thing when you rapped and you said okay
I can eat again what was the first thing
that you went for that you that you list
actually able to eat Sunday you have a
cheat day and I would say that you know
I love food buddy so when it's narrowed
down to the fact that you have this one
meal a week then I ended up it was pizza
or pasta it was like I woke up on
Sundays and I loved rails it's pizza day
and I remember I even clocked myself
sometimes when I had it in front of me
because I could probably then eat it in
about two minutes I was like I'm gonna
take my time I'm gonna slice each five
ten minutes so I actually get to
experience so I worked out with Magnus
about a month ago don't say yeah so you
know I don't I mean you did that every
day for nine months you said yeah
because I did it for 3-4 months leading
up to the shoot of them throughout the
shoot two things I learned note three
things I learned through that workout
number one it's an ass-kicker first of
all number two you're a badass for doing
so and number three like I didn't know
all of the lists of celebrity clients he
did and then when I think those people
said his boss go and he's a dear friend
of mine
oh sweet from back home and he he he met
Magnus on Tarzan and then he's doing gal
in Wonder Woman next which is very
excited but Alice texted me was that I
saw that you're gonna do Tomb Raider you
need to call my cousin am I gonna look
like you in Tulsa
well Magnus said Alexander is a beast he
said he's out beast in the gym like that
he's crazy
um yeah didn't you and Alexander's dad
did you get it recently meat like that
just Kate and principle did you go to
dinner his dad his dad yes that was his
dad oh yeah I know the whole family are
there like tons of brothers they're all
actors yeah so did you go as well I did
yeah what was that like meeting them
that was yeah I mean I was freaking out
I was like I was calling I was like
looking at this invitation I was like
are there any like rules I'm I said I'm
in Group B I didn't even know what that
meant but I was caught it into a room
and put in a corner with stellan
skarsgård so nervous like Oh am i
shaking with the wrong hand am i gonna
trip am I gonna do yeah I said yeah I
mean I was I had the Swedish Prime
Minister on my left and William on the
right but they were it was very very
sweet and it was actually a really fun
dinner yeah speaking back about Laura
Croft did you watch the angelina's
movies before because I thought this is
really neat to kind of get figure out
how we got there
yeah yes I saw the films when they came
out Angelina Jolie's made her into the
icon that cheers and I played the games
when when I was a kid but it's been
amazing to see cuz this character has
been with us for 22 years now and she
has really kind of evolved fruit through
time through the different games and
reboots or films and she kind of feels
like she's shaped
due to the time that she's in now it's a
lara croft that i think it 2018
audience will be able to relate to i
want to go back to the workouts for a
second cuz i am just a bit obsessed with
it i mean how you looked and how strong
you were at an athletic you were how
much of that like all of the the stunts
know that how much did you do and was
there ever time where they told you like
you got a chill first second yeah I mean
there's a few things that I weren't
allowed to do because of endurance isn't
that it
you know actually dangerous and you have
stunt women who practice for a long time
to do them but part from like three four
things I did all of it myself and and
then you have amazing stunts that this
is on even even if you do your own
stunts on all films then they have kind
of doubled
you know stunts who can do it as well
because sometimes you need to do so many
takes before all the kind of big shots I
at least wanted to try because I loved
that I loved the training and and and
and in my line of work I love the fact
that it's such a wonderful thing to get
introduced I'm so professional pretender
I normally have just a little amount of
time trial fool everybody that I can do
something we got well that's also a
wonderful thing because you are thrown
into so many different skills or if it's
a music industry or instrument or if
it's a language or if it's stunts it's a
wonderful thing to kind of let go and
embrace yourself into this new thing at
the peak of your performance you or
Michael which one of you guys could do
the most pull-ups did you ever chat was
likely like babe I'm come on I mean she
likes to be able to I mean I remember
the first time when I was able to lift
my own weight because it was it was
actually I was not that cool cuz it kind
of want to look like this but I was also
just so surprised I was doing it and
excited so it was like this mix of
emotion of being like cool excited and
just like this is actually happening
it's a really good time for you it's
really are you settled into like your
new life and honeymoon and I mean
newlywed and all that good stuff I feel
I'm very happy it's been a really good
year and I'm excited for all things
lying forward with this film coming out
and yeah I love it
okay cool thank you
[Music]